welcome back to uncensor with me Rosanna
Lockwood now in March the U.S power
lifting governing body ruled they would
allow trans women to compete in female
competitions north of the Border in
Canada the rules however seem to be very
relaxed with reports that athletes can
compete under whatever gender they feel
like on any given day apparently with no
proof needed and then
self-identification now April Hutchinson
is a competitive power lifter she's now
speaking up claiming it's unfair to
biological women and she's even been
threatened with a ban from her sport for
expressing her views she says Ann Andres
a trans woman currently holds the
highest deadlift of all time in Canada
and just announced she will attempt to
go to the world championship so should
we Embrace inclusivity in sports or are
women failing to be protected in sports
April Hutchison joins us now to talk
through this April thank you very much
for making time to speak to us I know
you're a very busy woman you've actually
just been competing in Grand Cayman I
hope that went well for you and just
talk to us a little bit for an
international audience give us a sense
of what you're campaigning about
yeah so actually um I've been a power
lifter with the Canadian part of the
thing Union for about four years now
over the last year I have been basically
I guess fighting my Federation
um to ban uh I guess trans women
um also known as men to be competing
with women in in powerlifting they have
basically ignored my pleas as well as
many other women who don't agree with it
and they've actually even threatened to
suspend me for speaking up about the
matter
um I don't know if you saw my speech a
couple weeks ago I was in the USA and I
basically told a very heartfelt speech
about you know the discriminate or the
basically them the threatening me to
suspend me off of Team Canada
um I just competed last week with Team
Canada I was allowed to go but the the
threats keep coming and um you know
disciplinary action for speaking up has
been ongoing for the last year do you
think this is a specific difference
between the US and Canada or other
countries in Canada is Canada
particularly inclusive when it comes to
this
yeah that's the thing is
um Canada I mean I'm not going to use
the Expression woke but I mean we have a
prime minister here Justin Trudeau who
actually on International women's day
tweeted that trans women are women so
there's our leadership of the country
um but no Canada is very
um I guess very lenient with with
policies like you mentioned our policy
basically you do not need any proof my
boyfriend could basically walk in
tomorrow identify as a female compete
and then the next day you know go back
to being a man again no proof no ID
required just basically going on how you
feel that day or whatever gender you
want to identify as yeah mind our
viewers just a few months ago a
powerlifting coach Avi silverberg
actually did this uh went into a
competition I think in Canada and
basically competed as a man and smashed
it
here he is and he didn't say I'm a woman
or maybe he did just to get past the uh
the regulations but did it in order to
prove your point really April didn't he
that um a man can just walk into a
competition and just trans trance
everyone there but let's make a
distinction here with Anne Andrus who we
we talked about in the introduction to
you that's somebody you know personally
and that is seems to be a source of a
lot of angst here this is Anne Andrews
competing uh a trans woman or as you you
call him a trans identifying person uh
previously born a biological male
transitioned a long time ago but post
puberty and I believe that's correct and
uh is uh taking on a lot of Records
um talk to us about what that's been
like for you
yeah so Anne actually just broke the the
national records for all the master
records yesterday while competing at the
Western regions he also holds the second
highest deadlift in uh our powerlifting
Federation of all time of all ages we're
talking 20 and up
um he just turned 40 so he is a 40 40
year old uh six foot 250 pound man and
you know it's it's been very
disheartening
um for example that National Record that
he broke
athletes have been chasing that for
years and we're talk we're talking top
athletes who have been training and
training and training
um you know so he just goes to show the
advantages the physical physiological
advantages that a male has over a female
whether it's muscle mass or bone density
lung capacity you know I could go on but
um it's been very disheartening a lot of
women actually yesterday dropped out of
the competition because they knew that
Anne would be lifting so they dropped
they quit they wrote to the Federation
and the Federation basically did nothing
about it I I can understand the enormous
frustration to be correct Frank because
when it comes to sports and it's all
about the the physicality of what you're
doing and to put it simply it's just it
it must be terribly frustrating
especially in power lifting which is so
much to do with strength and like why do
you think powerlifting is behaving
differently here you're talking about
your Federation compared to other sports
when it comes to things like swimming in
athletics where internationally we have
seen different policy lives
you know what Rosanna it's it's
mind-boggling we ask ourselves that
every day because I was talking to a
couple of the doctors the chief medical
doctors uh with the international
powerlifting Federation who right now
are actually working so hard around the
clock to try to have the policy changed
you have a new Senate powerlifting is a
strength based sport there's a 60
advantage in powerlifting alone between
men and female
um you know we've seen us UCI cycling
has changed just recently the
international weightlifting Federation
has now created a separate category for
transgender and that's with the the
Olympic lifting right that's a little
different than power of the thing but
still a strength sport uh World
Athletics swim Canada every Federation
has even gotten rid of the testosterone
monitoring that's that's been kind of
like as a term an outdated policy right
now so I just I don't get why power left
especially my Federation why they are
not uh you know they must be afraid
probably to get sued possibly
um you know it's it's mind-boggling I
ask myself that question every day April
um just before we let you go what do you
hope to achieve uh what would you like
to see happen within the next few months
well you know what my main goal you know
even if I wasn't powerlifting I my main
goal is to have fairness for women in
sports around the world globally
Canada is probably on the top of the
list because we have no policy we
actually have a trans inclusion policy
we have no policy at all to protect
women and girls in sports so I mean if I
if I put powerlifting to the back door
tomorrow and I didn't parlift ever again
so be it but I will keep being vocal and
I will keep speaking out about fairness
because we know women deserve that it's
completely unfair it's bodies that play
sports not identities remember it's
bodies in biology not identities that
play sports uh April I think it would be
a tremendously sad if you find yourself
with joy from the sport but we really
appreciate you sharing your views and
your experience this evening thank you
thank you so much well let's cross to
the studio still joined by Grace Blakely
also talk TV contributor Esther cracker
who are both listening into that and
look I know we've all potentially got
very different positions on this uh but
we are all women uh my position is that
you know obviously I'm pretty
sympathetic to trans rights and I feel
they're a marginalized and oppressed
group mostly but when it comes to sport
it's a little more complicated because
of the physicality of it Grace yeah I
don't disagree I mean I think you know
this quite obviously this has become a
culture War actually right so it's like
you're either on one extreme or the
other you're either for trans women be
able to compete in sports or you're
against it
um and actually this is very clearly
something that needs to be decided by
sporting bodies on a case-by-case basis
and also on a literally on a
case-by-case basis so you need to be
looking at the athlete in question
looking at whether or not there is one
person dominating a sport and then it
just becomes not entertaining to watch
so you need to think about how you're
doing the rules there and it's not just
trans people it's also intersex people I
remember we had the South African runner
who was bad from competing exactly on
the basis she had high testosterone
levels so clearly we're at this point
now where because often because
um you know competitive sports like this
have grown so much and they've become so
much more popular there's a range of
different people competing that the
rules which gave rise to the separation
of men and women's sports are being
reconsidered and do we need to now think
of something like you know we're testing
athletes based on
um maybe you know like hormone levels
testosterone levels along with other
metrics of how their body performs under
stress along with thinking about you
know if they're trans did they
transition pre or post teenager Hood
like all of these things need to be
decided very specifically not just this
culture War you know battle I mean the
lady said something which is I think is
probably the the Pinnacle of this debate
which is biology over identity on the
issue of intersex people yes I do think
it should be a case-by-case basis and
people are born with you know
chromosomal disorders and all of that
that's that's fine that's biology right
but on the issue of of transgenderism
that's an identity issue right it's also
a biology well it's not a violence there
are biologies all the time but the thing
is we take the pill with they are not
fundamentally they're not altering every
single cell in their body which is every
single cell in your body is a marker of
what your sex is so that's completely
different on the issue of intersex I
don't think you can I you know conflate
that with transgenderism because you
can't choose to be intersex you can
choose to be transgender well I mean
people would argue that you can't but I
think regardless but that that is that
is the bottom line I think obviously and
I I know we all we all agree that at
some point in the weeks or weeks or
months that we do this job we will talk
about trans issues and we're just like
why again because we haven't simplified
what the rule should be and this is the
thing we're not most people don't
disagree I've always said there should
be a trans category for most sports not
because I'm going to be sitting at the
front room watching but because this
will just this will solve the whole
debate they get representation they get
to compete there is no you know issue of
how female athletes feel or male
athletes or any of this there's none of
this confusion and they get to compete
and they get feel represented I don't
know why we're not championing that more
championing that more that would solve
this whole problem but really if we keep
going down to all but it's not my fault
I'm trans or whatever look you have your
own league case closed let's talk about
the economy or taxes you know I'll
always talk about the economy a lot of
my numbers me uh both of you thank you
very much for giving your Insight and
the opinion on that story uh yes we do
cover this issue a lot but I think it
was very interesting to hear Bill
Hutchinson's experience uh this evening